[Music]
welcome
to the mit center for art science and
technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science of contemporary computation
cast was established in 2012 with the
goal of building
and building on connections between the
worlds of art science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and as with its predecessors
we bring together artists scientists
engineers and humanists
from within mit and from the world at
large to discuss areas of rapidly
evolving research and urgent social
relevance
and defined in that dialogue stimulation
confirmation
provocation intersection and we hope
common purpose at mit
cast partners with departments labs and
centers to integrate the arts across the
curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide support to
faculty and members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice and or research
in addition to symposia like this cass
facilitates the sharing of this creative
work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic
technical and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media we also look
forward to seeing you
on friday april 9th as the symposium
culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
[Music]
i understood
[Music]
time i don't see it
[Music]
welcome to unfolding intelligence the
art and science of contemporary
computation
thank you for joining us and for
bringing your curiosity and attention
with you today
deep time and intelligence unfolding
models
open systems bias in a.i
even in this sheer titular variety i
hope you might hear whispers of the
ambitions afoot
could the discussion of artificial
intelligence be reorganized by the
thoughts and work of those who question
ai
who cautiously embrace and reshape it to
their needs
and from particular perspectives those
who work with
and through it grounding our ideas about
and response to ai
in such practices that operate within
the orbit of these situated
bases of reflection perhaps then
rather than being strung along by
stories about inevitable outcomes
impacts and profits etc
all reasoning that assumes the essence
of ai is a sure thing
that its effect on us and our role in
shaping it are readily apprehensible
relations with a stable thing a
predictable future
relieving ourselves of that over
exposure
of ai to intellectual sureties we may
sense a moment in which an instrument of
optimization
and automation becomes a medium open to
reuse and comment
tinkering and informed reflection even a
generator
of surprise results keep time and
intelligence
the portion of the discussion at hand in
this panel
we will see that ai can help us to
consider fundamental questions about how
sensations
sounds movements choreographies of form
and matter
take shape in time gain coherence as
objects and structures through training
and learning recursion and iteration
deep time yes
in terms of the evolutionary time scales
that work in growth and form from the
diatom to the social
but also deep as in downward to the nano
and minute intervals of the fold of a
protein or crack in a crystal lattice
ai seems to assist us in traveling to
scales at which primordial logical
formalisms operate in dimensions
and through structures that defy our
concepts and intuitions
but perhaps not those of feature
detection
capacities exacting computations
can process holly herndon artist
composer
performer has built and conceptualized
for us a way of thinking
music in the context of a longed array
of ritualized
entrainment gary tomlinson yale
musicologist provides connections
between the story of evolution and the
unfolding of ai research
that few could account for given the
myriad methods and fields of research
that he has been able to synthesize
building connections between humanities
and sciences
for us marcus buehler material scientist
here at mit
challenges us to think of ai as
something capable of detecting
homologies of structure across scales of
existence
perhaps even giving us new ways of
thinking about universals across scales
antonio taralba computer scientist at
with
csail here at mit moves not between
scales but across modes of sensation
using ai to link sound division and
movement to sound
proposing a multimodal sensory field for
ai
i shall withhold any further attempt at
synthetic remarks at present
and listen now with you all to the
thoughts of this wonderful group
inviting you to listen with me for hints
of how ai might be providing new insight
into form and structure cohering at
divergent
length scales time scales and between
modalities of sensation and varying
protocols of entrainment it is important
also now to acknowledge that it is not
we
the speakers nor mit who claim authority
over or seek final say
regarding the deep or any ultimate
meaning of ancient ancestry
mit acknowledges indigenous peoples as
the traditional stewards of the land
and the enduring relationship that
exists between them and their
traditional territories
the land over which circuits sustaining
mit send their signals to your screens
is the traditional unseated territory
of the wapanoag nation we offer our
partial perspectives
in acknowledging that we have much to
learn and that an acknowledgement such
as this is only a small first step
towards remembering and working through
the painful histories
of genocide and forced occupation that
the wampanoag nation
suffered land on which many diverse
indigenous groups gathered since time
immemorial
my name is william lockett i'm the
current mel and post doctoral
fellow with the center for art science
and technology you'll see me at the q
a leading the discussion and also taking
your questions through twitter
thank you and see you then
good morning afternoon or evening thank
you for watching i'm gary tomlinson
provocative titles are meant not merely
to provoke but to draw us in
and one of the more compelling instances
i've come across recently is this one
from a 2020 article by j mark
bishop artificial intelligence is stupid
and causal reasoning won't fix it
the essay opposes computationalism the
idea that human intelligence is a
strictly computational affair
and it argues that ai since it is a
computational affair
can't duplicate the feats of human-like
understanding
bishop's article is one in a long line
opposed to computationalism
both as an approach to the human brain
and as a way of making a machine that
might act like it
and he takes us on a quick tour of some
of his predecessors from girdle's
incompleteness theorem
as developed by john lucas and roger
penrose to john searle's chinese room
riffing on the distinction of formal
syntax from semantics
then building on hillary putnam's idea
that all open systems are in effect
finite state automata bishop reasons
that equating mind with computation
leads inevitably inevitably to pan
psychism
to the assignment of mind to every open
system to a rock
for example
what worries me about much writing of
this sort is this proliferation of key
words that are rarely defined as clearly
as they need to be
bishop's review runs through a litany of
them it's true that he mostly avoids the
vagus
terms mind and consciousness but here
are some difficult words he does rely on
that call out for unpacking but receive
little
understanding as in the human-like
understanding that automata don't
achieve
or meaning as in the meaning of words
computational machines can't grasp
other key words that pop up are synonyms
for meaning semantics and content both
appear in bishop's discussion of
searle's chinese room argument
two more difficult keywords are
experience and salience
is salience dependent on experience or a
part of it or a generator of it
what is experience and how does salience
come about
in this lexical thicket meaning is for
me the key word of keywords
and we can expand the list of closely
related terms beyond searle's content
and semantics
reference representation aboutness
intentionality just to give four
examples
in my remarks today i want to make two
observations about meaning and its
synonym cluster
observations that seem to be relevant to
the possibilities of a strong ai or an
agi
artificial general intelligence the
first observation
concerns the foundation of meaning which
i locate in
semiosis that is in sign making the
theory i draw on
here is generally humanistic in
orientation
the second observation concerns the
origins and extent of the meaning that
arises from semiosis and here
my theoretical base is in evolutionary
science to look ahead
these observations will lead me toward a
couple of general caveats regarding
machine intelligence
first in order to see the challenges of
designing a machine capable of
understanding meanings
we need a firm grasp of the nature of
meaning itself
this requires a distinction that i
regard as fundamental and ontological
between information transmission
a basic process to all life forms
and sign making a particular kind of
information transmission restricted
to a very small proportion of those life
forms
information transmission of the first
sort no matter how powerful or elaborate
can't lead to meaning content or
aboutness because it can't create
signs only a machine capable of semiotic
information could create or understand
meaning second once we see the
distinction between information in
general and the special case of semiotic
information
we discern more clearly the evolved
capacities that enable the creation of
science and hence meaning
these are not identifiable traits
possessed by particular organisms
not adaptations selected for particular
functions
such selection for is not how natural
selection works
it's not an optimization problem
notwithstanding dan dennett's a
decades-long effort
to make us think it is the capacities to
create meaning are instead ongoing
processes of negotiation with an
external world
and so they can't be identified as
discrete properties of an organism
processes not properties this is a model
that should hang above the door of every
evolutionist
it already hangs above the doors of many
these processes are signaled in the
radical niche construction of my title
okay so much for looking ahead let's
start with the distinction of
non-semiotic and semiotic information
the first could be called information
pure and simple or shannon information
but i'll call call it causal information
since it's a matter of causal covariance
as jerry fodor once put it
its transmission along some kind of
channel brings about some corresponding
effect at the receiving end
information of this sort is a relational
thing the channels can feedback from
receiver to sender
they can be networked in parallel and
serial fashion
doubled and re-doubled again and
hierarchized in any number of routines
and subroutines
but the fundamental relationality of
covariance remains
all living things even the simplest
bacterium
are complex miracles of this kind of
information processing
but their information in the vast
majority of organisms is not about
anything it's without content or meaning
a sheer
causality that makes things happen from
the molecular level
on up in scale through organismal and
ecosystemic levels
it brings about correlated difference in
the complex systems that work at all
these levels
semiotic information is something
different that arises on the foundation
of causal information
it depends not on systems of relations
alone but on
a relation to a relation a meta relation
this requires something more complex
than the shannon model of transmitter
channel and receiver
and something different even from the
idea of a hierarchy of routines
it requires something so complex in fact
that it has emerged only in a tiny
percentage of the life forms our out
our biosphere has known while all life
forms are processors of causal
information
very few are creators of semiotic
information
this basic distinction of causal and
semiotic information is relevant to the
question of meaning because
meaning is founded in the sign meta
relation
signs are always signs of they introduce
aboutness in the world by virtue of this
fundamental nature
introducing at the same time what we
connote by all the synonyms
named above content semantics and so
forth
signs are representational in the exact
sense of representing one thing
in another this is what signs do
it's not what causal information does
signs are not the same as signals
in the way this word is loosely but
pervasively used by biologists
a signal is non-semiotic and usually
comes down to a threshold mechanism in
the operation of causal information
it doesn't represent one thing in
another
a meta relation is required for semiosis
most basically
because a sign is something different
than a cause of its object
it is instead an analysis of its object
it divides up the
object picking out certain aspects of it
to use in representing it
it's complexity it's complexly
constrained in the picking
both by its own nature and by the nature
of the object
signs and their objects never mesh
completely that would collapse the sign
into the object
collapsing at the same time aboutness
and content
there's no representing in identity
but what is it that enters into this
complex
relation between aspects of one entity
and aspects of another
what is the added something that creates
the meta relation
this is a third entity one capable of
forming percepts of certain sorts
it doesn't exercise sovereign control
over these percepts
instead it's called into the aspectual
constraints of what will become
sign and object called by their nature
as affordances in the world
its percepts are always formed not only
by its own capacities but also by the
entities that come to form sign an
object
semiosis is in this way a process of
reciprocal constraint
reciprocal affordance if you like among
a percept
and things or phenomena external to it
it's a niche constructive process
those of you familiar with the
philosophy of charles sanders purse
will recognize in this approach to
semiotics two basic persian tenets
the first of is the partial aspectual
nature
of all the relations in the sign making
process
from his scrutiny of this partiality
viewed in its many combinatorial
possibilities
sprang the many typologies of signs that
purse offered
the second tenet is the calling of a
perceiver into the aspectual parsing of
the world
an idea for which perce coined the term
interpretant
this is a fundamental term in his
philosophy but one that has been much
misunderstood
it involves no interpretation as we tend
to use that word
but relies instead on the perceptual
capacity to vibe to divide up the world
to parse it as i've said registering
some of its parts
clumping some things together with
others and relating itself to those
relations how do some life forms come to
be able to form interpretance
memory is crucial but not merely the
simplest forms of storage and retrieval
instead something like an episodic
memory is necessary
a mechanism that can retrieve memories
as parts of whole situations
retrieve them more readily because of
those situations
and enrich and relive the situations in
the retrieval
some animals besides humans are capable
of such episodic memory
most animals and all other organisms are
not
learning is also central but learning of
an advanced sort dependent on
episodic memory simple associative
learning is a purely relational thing
and occurs in many many creatures
without any semiosis
as a function of simple neural nets
involving excitation and inhibition
connected with innate
reward or punishment signals a
well-studied example is the sucrose
sensitivity
sensitivity of honeybees on the basis of
which they learn complex associations
concerning food sources
and much else this is non-semiotic
learning
on the other hand the learning of a
songbird for example to rank the varied
challenges from the songs of its
neighbors
or to sing by itself a pseudo-duet
suggesting to other birds that it's mate
is present when it's not
these are semiotic through and through
they depend in each case on the
retrieval and processing
of whole episodes from a bird's life and
from these
they parse aspects that conduce to
interpretant formation
memory learning and finally attention
attention is a more basic capacity
than memory or learning and it too comes
in more and less complex forms
it's related even in its simplest forms
to the salience i mentioned before the
way an organism can single out a
particular stimulus from all those
coming to it
the sensitivity of honeybees to sucrose
again provides a good example
for semiosis a more complex attentional
capacity is required
one that can sustain a recursive
analysis of incoming stimuli
taking them apart into their aspects and
focusing on them at both comprehensive
and partial
levels in this analytic or parsing
function
attention enables the construction of
episodes in memory and learning
building memories as aspects of broader
situations
studies of such complex attention
suggest that it's the product
of mediations of information in which
salience filters proximate
to sensory input interface with further
processing and modulation downstream
interface that is with top-down systems
higher up in the mid-brain and forebrain
such neural mediations are i think
fundamental to the emergence of semiotic
information and i'll touch on them again
later
attention memory learning these
foundations for semiosis are not as i
said before
discrete properties of certain animals
but instead processes
in their engagements with their niches
recognizing the flexible
flexible complexity of these processes
is what has recently
radicalized the ideas of niche
construction
let's step back for a moment in general
niche construction refers to the
reciprocal or feedback process by which
organisms build their selective
environments
as those environments build them its
construction has tended to be thought
thought of as a dynamic operating across
long time scales
with environments and populations of
organisms slowly shifting in tandem with
one another
the ancestors of beavers for example
gradually adapting
to aquatic life even as their behaviors
created more and more aquatic
environments
alterations in the niche brought about
by organisms
bring about shifting selective dynamics
which eventually alter the genomes of
those organisms
now what i'm terming radical niche
construction involves recognizing
the pervasive plasticity of niche
constructive feedback
across all biotic scales of time and
space
we now see that niche construction is
not only a long-term process but also
the plastic responsiveness
of all organisms to their changing
environments operating
at a much quicker pace
natural selection has resulted not in
fixed capacities with discrete
advantageous functions
so much as in the flexibility by which
the nodal systems that make up organisms
open out to myriad aspects of their
environments and
this is most important this plasticity
reaches
from the niche all the way to genes
which turn out to be nothing like
blueprints for life
forms but instead are open information
systems in constant flux with the
situations around them
an example can come once again from
honeybees dozens of pheromones are
crucial in the intricate regulation of
the honeybee colony or superorganism
they're produced of course by individual
bees according to complex
bioinformational pathways
involving genes rna transcription of
various sorts
proteins that genes construct and more
but the pathways run in both directions
the genetic instructions are regulated
by the proteins they produce
which in turn are regulated by the
external circulation of the pheromones
they help to produce
brief exposure to a single chemical in
the cocktail that functions as an alarm
pheromone alters factors
inducing rna transcription in the
olfactory centers of the b
brain allowing genes to be expressed
that activate
fight or flight and aggression pathways
in higher brain regions which then
modulate b behavior an hour after such
exposure
the resulting information cascades have
up and down regulated the expression of
hundreds of genes
laying a foundation for heightened
responsiveness to subsequent alarms
the whole network extending from niche
to genes has been altered in the blink
of an eye
or the whiff of ascent similar cascades
regulate it is now clear the genomic
expression of all
life forms
with such radical niche construction in
mind let's return to semiosis and ask
where we might seek neural substrates
for the interpretant and the meta
relation
i think we need to seek them not simply
in the redoubling of parallel processing
in large brains
and not even only in the serial
extension in such branch of processing
along a sequence of distinct modules
though both of these are probably play a
role
an additional element of neural
architecture is built on top of these
bringing
massive parallelism and serialism to
bear
in modulating the processing of other
connected centers
instead of peripheral sensory neurons
connecting directly to the highest
processing centers
large vertebrate brains have processors
connected to processors
all reconnected in loops of feedback
systems
the song system in a song bird's brain
provides an example
this is often divided into three systems
two pathways controlling song learning
song learning memorization and
production and a third pathway for
auditory
production auditory processing
the slide i'm showing you divides these
into two sagittal sections of the brain
with the vocal pathways on the left
and the auditory pathway on the right
it's easy to see that the systems are
networked in immensely complex ways
involving
many nuclei each with large numbers of
neurons
the auditory nuclei are linked to the
song control ones
linking left and right hand diagrams in
other words and
bringing audition directly to bear on
memory and learning
especially important for the semiotic
complexity of birdsong i think
is the mediating role of the thalamus in
these networks situated between
mid and hindbrain and higher cognitive
functions
notice that it doesn't merely relay
process sensory input to higher brain
regions
but is a part of loops from those
regions involved
in both song production and audition
in mammals the thalamus is a midbrain
processing station mediating top-down
and bottom-up networks
is it's implicated in attentional focus
voluntary motor behavior
memory and learning and so it seems to
be in songbirds
there's nothing nearly as elaborated as
these networks in the brain of a
honeybee
here by contrast is a diagram of the
network for sucrose sensitivity and
responses that i
that i mentioned before the relevant
part of this diagram is the red arrow
tracing a single long neuron that
projects from the proboscis
through the antennal lobes to higher
brain regions the so-called mushroom
bodies
and to the green motor control center
the complexity
built into this tiny brain is truly
awesome but is far outstripped by the
bird brain's multiplicity of distinct
modules their serial and parallel
connections
and their intricate feedback mediation
through distinct levels of processing
it's not merely the complexity of neural
architecture however that brings about
the cognitive functions of
interpretation sign
and meaning to achieve this we need to
set this network in motion as a process
rather than an architecture and the
motion comes about
through the radical niche constructed
plasticity in the face of changing
affordances
i spoke about before the informational
complexities
i exemplified with the alarm pheromones
of bees
altering gene expression on a
moment-to-moment basis
are at work in all animal brains and
extensively studied in songbirds
they seem to foster a varied and complex
processing of the world proportionate to
the varied complexity of the brain
architectures they enliven
it's from this i think that a new fold
is introduced into the experience of
certain animals
from this that they gain the parsing
power that makes their percepts analytic
and at the same time opens those
percepts to the formative rebound from
the things they analyze
the calling into the interpretant from
this fold this recursive percept arises
the cognizance of a relation
in perception to a relation of things in
the world the essence of the sign and
meaning
let's return finally to the challenges
facing the project of an ai that could
construct and understand meaning
what should be apparent from my quick
overview of the foundations of animal
meanings first
is the wild over optimism of rodney
brooks brooks's assertion
around 1990 that his robots were
approximating even insect levels of
intelligence
the complexities of b behavior depend on
modest attention
memory and learning all rendered
processual and reactive to the changing
world
by systems of gene regulations linked
through cellular pathways
out to external stimuli in insects
these are all causal informational
complexities
they do not manifest the meta-relation
or create semiotic information
so the first step in making a thinking
machine would be to come somewhere close
to the complexities of radical niche
construction evident
even in non-semiotic creatures
complexities
that are still not fully appreciated 30
years after rodney brooks has embedded
embodied and situated ai
this would give robots an ability to
react to their environments in ways that
resemble the plastic genomic shifts of
living organisms
this is a very high bar for machining
intelligence even surpassing it however
wouldn't endow a machine
with the ability to create aboutness and
meaning
for this further leap we'd need to
marshal systems of systems of the sword
exemplified by our songbird and then
harness them to the plastic capacity
animals show to remake the systems in
moment-to-moment negotiation with their
niches
the machine would need complex
attentional capacities meshing high
and low level processing it would need
episode episodic memory recalling whole
situations in his past and shaping its
learning on the basis of them
and all these systems would need to
submit themselves to a ceaseless
alteration on every scale
starting from the smallest generative
ones the genes in the machine
so to speak which could not be conceived
as fixed entities
now i'm not an expert in ai or indeed
any kind of computation
my only programming experience was a
course in basic i took 50 years ago at
dartmouth college
taught as i remember it by john kemeny
himself or perhaps he only visited the
class leaving its day-to-day operation
to his graduate students
but i posed the question to those who do
know about ai
are we coming close to all this can all
the evolutionary algorithms
deep learning and meta-heuristics of
today's ai
begin to glimpse the lifeways of animals
that bring about meaning in the world
can they approach even a lesser standard
the autopoetic intelligence of a
honeybee
thank you very much
hi my name is holly herndon i'm a
composer and artist based in berlin
working largely with music and
technology um i'll start this talk
with a little background about my work
and then i'll talk about my most recent
project
proto where i'm incorporating machine
learning
so movement was my first album released
in 2012
and for this album i built custom
digital processes for vocal performance
really in search of an embodied
electronic music performance practice
and around that time i was coming to the
conclusion that the laptop is the most
intimate instrument i have ever known
you know and at the time
it was still somewhat controversial to
see laptops in the concert hall
as a as a concert instrument
so by introducing the processed voice it
created a kind of bridge
to traditional performance practice
i released platform in 2015 as my second
album and i worked with matt dryhurst
and medihaven on that project
around that time i was coming to the
conclusion that if the laptop
was my primary instrument then the
internet was really an extended part of
that
i began to focus on the mediated
relationships that i was having online
and i started making music from sampling
my own online activities
around that time i was also touring
rather extensively
off the back of my first album movement
and i began to feel like i was more at
home
with my email inbox than um
necessarily my apartment um that i
would barely even see um and so
in the wake of edward snowden's
allegations i realized that a lot of
those really private
moments and gestures might not be so
private in the end
um and that every gesture made online
might hypothetically be
considered a performance for a kind of
unannounced observer
so the intimacy i had established with
movement felt compromised or violated
but for me there was really no turning
back at that point it already was my
primary instrument
so i really needed to kind of understand
what this new paradigm meant for the art
form
the album proto was released in 2019 and
i'm going to spend a little bit of time
talking about that and the work that
that led to
that i've been focusing on in the last
couple years
when i first started working with
machine learning i was looking into the
history a bit and i i found several
examples of people
creating automated composition machines
so that's this idea of
training a machine learning algorithm on
bach and then receiving
infinite variations of bach
but i also came across a kind of
different
perspective on machine learning a
different approach
when i learned about george lewis and
his voyager project which was developed
in the late 80s and early 90s at earcam
and so lewis was attempting to create a
kind of ensemble member
that he could improvise alongside so
rather than seeing the machine learning
tool
as a replacement um to himself as a
composer
he rather saw this as a kind of
augmentation or
a way that he could perform alongside a
machine learning algorithm which i found
really interesting and inspiring
um so he was trying to embed
the kind of musical decisions and
aesthetics of the community that he was
surrounded with
um through the aacm and a lot of the
improv scene
in african-american circles in chicago
and he was trying to to embed
a lot of the aesthetics from this
specific community
into the voyager system and i really
love that his work really acknowledges
that aesthetics and musical decisions
actually come from somewhere they're
human cultural decisions that come from
humans interacting with one another
musically in space together
so this is our machine learning project
that we named spawn
and this is her cover debut and her
birthday is listed
as 2017. and the reason why we use this
kind of
metaphor of a baby of an inhuman baby of
a kind of early life
we found this metaphor really useful and
that
spawn really only has access to the
information that we as a community give
her
and and really foster her with the data
that we're feeding her so we found this
as a way to not only talk about the
importance of
you know kind of her daily diet but also
the
communal nature and kind of raising this
kind of nascent
intelligence early on we decided to work
with audio rather than midi files
midi as a machine legible musical score
for a few primary reasons for one thing
a midi score loses a lot of the
performance detail that audio captures
so certain terminal
and performance expressions are really
difficult to capture in a midi file
also we didn't want to use actual scores
from the past
from ourselves or from others as it
would encourage us to make similar
compositional decisions
rather than new decisions responding to
the world around us
we view composition as a living
breathing art form
and we feared that if we trained on past
work we might find ourselves in a kind
of
aesthetic cul-de-sac where we're just
kind of recreating
musical decisions of the past and lastly
we also wanted to use our own data
that we could compensate people and
give credit for so we created all of our
own data sets
there's a lot of entitlement happening
in the field of machine learning
when it comes to using other people's
data our kind of shared human archive
and so i'll speak about that a little
bit later but it was really important to
us that we were able to create our own
data sets
so this is an early example that was
trained on my speaking voice and i'm
using a recurrent neural network for
this
i love how kind of rough and imperfect
that early experiment was
so this led to godmother where it sounds
like
spawn's almost kind of beatboxing this
music
which is really funny because i didn't
actually train the model
to beatbox but there was spoken word and
sung passages and of course when those
two combine that creates a kind of beat
boxing
and already you can kind of hear that
you know
spawn can kind of outperform me in many
ways there's there's no limit on
the pitch range of spawn i really see
this as building on some of my early
experiments with
digital vocal processing which was
really a way for me to kind of transcend
some of the physical limitations of my
body and this
for me was kind of the next step in that
so to be able to create a voice model
of my own voice which didn't really have
to adhere to the laws of physics of my
own body
so parallel to my work developing spawn
i was also working with a vocal ensemble
in berlin much in the lineage of george
lewis
we decided to work with spawn as an
ensemble member
training her on various members voices
so she could perform certain parts that
we composed
alongside the ensemble so you can see
her sitting on top of the piano for this
kind of group shot and this is about
half of the ensemble there's
around 10 members in total as these
worlds came together i started thinking
about machine learning as a kind of
human coordination technology
seeing parallels to early folk vocal
techniques
developed for group coordination or
cultural cohesion and ritual
and all of a sudden a singing ai
ensemble member made perfect sense
our ultimate goal is to be able to
perform
with our machine learning system live
but we're not quite there yet everything
that we recorded for the album
required rendering time that just wasn't
capable of a kind of real time low
latency performance
so we found a way to include
a machine learning aspect to our live
performances without having that
real-time system
we decided to invite the audience to
train spawn and a kind of
call-in response with our ensemble
and we're really trying to communicate
that as soon as a gesture
is captured in media photo video audio
whatever
it can become machine legible and can
then be part of a training canon
we have recordings from our audiences
all over the world
so we're able to create unique crowd
models for each
audience that we visit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
us while we
is
so this is really a huge topic to
condense into such a short
talk but i want to briefly touch on some
of the questions and ideas that arose
around machine learning and music
and i find it useful to look at sampling
as a precursor
this is an image of pierre schaefer
who's often credited as an
early pioneer of music concrete which
was an early recording
sampling and schaefer had a unique for
the time
opinion on how people might listen
to sounds decoupled from their sound
source so for example
if you listen to the sound of a train
the elevated listener in schaefer's mind
might be able to just think about the
aesthetic properties and the sonic
qualities of that train sound
without actually imagining the train
itself
and while this is a really interesting
concept when we apply that same idea
to human-made musical gestures such as
instrumental music or vocal music human
created when we
decontextualize the sound from its
source we also
erase the people who made those original
sounds we
we take away the accreditation component
and while sampling led to
incredible new genres of music from
hip-hop to electronica
um history is often told by the victors
and there were also some pretty
egregious examples where
people's work was used and widely
distributed and it was never compensated
so one of these failures of copyright
law is
gc coleman's drum break from the 1969
song amen brother
it's probably the most sampled drum beat
in history
i'm going to play this in a minute and
if you're familiar with genres such as
break beat or drum and bass this is the
essential
rhythmic foundation of these entire
genres that went on to sell
hundreds of thousands of records and
inspire musicians
across the world and unfortunately
coleman
when he passed away he was homeless and
was unaware of the success of his
sample and was never compensated for
that work
so the question is how do we not repeat
those same mistakes of the past
this led me to think about this concept
of vocal sovereignty so what does it
mean
to own one's own voice and there are a
few court cases that are interesting to
reference here
for one bette midler was approached by
mercury sable to
license one of her songs for a
commercial
and she rejected them so they hired a
bette midler
sing-alike and she was actually able to
successfully sue them that they had
infringed on her vocal likeness
and i'll just play a quick example so
you can hear how
her vocal articulation was really
mimicked by the
vocal sing alike
[Music]
so thinking about these voice models and
vocal likeness
vocal sovereignty made me ask a few
questions
what is an authentic voice and who owns
it
what role does influence inspiration and
appropriation have
how might we deal with influence when
it's automated
and can no longer operate under the
alibi of inspiration
or can a machine in fact be inspired
how do styles evolve over time and
what's the best way to acknowledge
influence this slide isn't intended to
flatten these
influence relationships but rather to
show that influence comes in different
forms across
generations not all influence
relationships are the same
what does it mean if these influences
can become fully automated
nina sun eischeim writes in the race of
sound
listening timbre and vocality in
african-american music
voice is not singular it's collective
voice is not innate
it's cultural she goes on to clarify
singing is always made up of entrainment
style and technique but is generally
mistaken for essence
so the voice is communal and we perform
as individuals
through it so with the history of
sampling in mind we came up with this
idea of spawning
how might machine learning tools address
some of the issues that sampling caused
in the last century
how might we build in better systems
from the beginning
to help avoid some of the pitfalls of
the past
the idea that we came up with we like to
call spawning
so individuals sample others with no
hard-coded attribution
that's sampling spawning attributes and
builds upon source or at least it could
individuals sample others with no
hard-coded payment
spawning pays its source sampling
repeats expressions from the past
spawning builds variations from past
expressions
sampling is one-to-one reproduction
spawning is smart and reproductive
given the enormous capabilities and
possibilities of machine learning models
and some of the
questions i brought up around vocal
sovereignty we think it's important to
be thinking about these issues from the
start
one idea i've been developing is called
hitmaker and it's a project in
collaboration with jj bird and matthew
dryhurst
and so this is a kind of contemporary
take on
a sampler using machine learning so the
idea is is you have a source
and then as soon as you load that source
into the tool it's registered so it can
be
automatically given kind of attribution
and then the next step leads to sound
separation and spawning which i'll
demonstrate
briefly here
[Applause]
so first we separate the kick and the
snare sound using a sound separation
algorithm
and using those as a kind of target
sound
we're able to spawn or create new
variations
on those original sounds
[Music]
so we're obviously working with very
simple percussive sounds in this
instance but you can imagine how one
might extrapolate
other instrument sounds um from an
original source
this is another project that we're
working on using google magenta's ddsp
system
which can transfer timbre from one
instrument to another
we're currently trying to make the
system work for real-time performance
this is an example of a voice being
transformed into a flute
um this is a collaboration i worked on
with maria arnall who's a catalan
vocalist and this is a song of sybil
acapella and then i'll play
the flute version so pay close attention
to the ornaments in her vocal and see
how closely they align
with the flute version
[Music]
he
[Music]
bye
[Music]
and lastly i'm working on an open source
model version of my voice that i'll be
able to share with the wider
public in about a month unfortunately i
can't share that
yet at this time but i'm really excited
to for that to come out so please stay
tuned for that
for those who are interested some of the
questions that came up through the
making of this last album and some of
the
the new tools that we're developing at
the moment um i discuss these issues on
a weekly basis with my partner matt
dryhurst on our podcast interdependence
the idea is that we're speaking with
people who we think are shaping 21st
century culture
often with a focus on the impact of
technology thank you so much for your
time
our visual system is amazing we can make
sense of the world around
us just by analyzing the light that
bounces of objects
and reaches our eyes to illustrate this
let me show you a movie
this will help you to appreciate how
amazing we are
this following video is showing a very
low quality movie recorded in my office
this movie is so blurry that many of the
objects are defined by
only one single pixel but our visual
system is so amazing that can recognize
a person talking on the phone listening
to some music
and working on a computer and it is
amazing that we are able to recognize so
much
from so little visual information
of course most of what we saw in this
video was not really there
most of what we saw in the video was
only inside
our heads and to illustrate this let's
watch the original
high resolution movie
as you can see now many of the objects
that you recognized before
were not really what you thought
so why is so difficult to build a
machine that sees
the same ways that humans do
well the input to a vision system an
image
is just a collection of numbers like the
ones shown here
each number represents a pixel intensity
at that location
the numbers do not directly tell us
which objects are in the picture
or even which numbers are part of an
object or part of the background
this is what a machine will see and what
we see here
if we look at the same numbers but
displayed on the form of a picture
then we see just a blurry picture of a
person walking
computer computer vision systems need to
be designed and trained
to see the person behind the numbers and
that's where the challenge resides
training a system capable of recognizing
objects in images generally requires
annotating manually thousands of images
where we will have to indicate what are
the objects in each picture
their boundaries and what the name is
and the system will then learn to
associate the image with the annotations
that we provided
and this process is very labor intensive
and it requires many hundreds of hours
of
manual labor
a different strategy that is currently
used
in research is to train systems using
computer graphics so for instance
the community is developing virtual
worlds
where you can interact with agents you
can see the world
recognize objects and train ai systems
in these virtual environments with the
hope that
later they will learn something that can
be transferred to the real world
but all these different ways of training
artificial vision systems
are very different to how babies
actually learn to perceive the world
and so let's watch a baby actually
learning
to to recognize things in the world
a baby learns most of the time by itself
there
is no supervision from the parents there
are no labels
and it learns by interacting with the
world by looking at things by hearing
the noise that they make by touching
them
and finally tasting them
[Music]
and a baby will learn to discover
objects to understand materials to
perceive a space
to manipulate objects via interaction
and it will do this through a very rich
set of sensory modalities
vision addition smell taste and touch
and it does this in a complete
unsupervised way
it doesn't require the type of
exhaustive annotations
that current ai systems need
to learn about the world so in this
presentation i will describe some of the
work in our groups
trying to build systems that leverage
different sensory modalities to learn to
perceive the world without supervision
so we started our work in 2016
with a very simple setting andrew owens
a psd a student at mit recorded video
and sounds
while he was sitting hitting surfaces
with a drumstick
for over a month he walked around with
the camera and a drumstick
and recorded many thousands of hits
so let me show some of his greatest hits
[Music]
he heated and scratched surfaces all
over mit
for a long a long time and he recovered
recorded
tens of thousands of these events
so with this data set we asked the
following question
given the video input without the audio
just the pixels is it possible to
predict
what the audio should be so we want to
build a system that will take us
input just the pixels just the frames of
the video
and it should produce the sounds that
should go with it
a system train to solve this audio
prediction task
should be able to solve the following
problems it will have to recognize the
drum stick
and it will have to detect when it is in
contact with the surface
and whether it was a hit or a scratch
you will have to recognize the type of
contact
the strength and the duration of the
contact you will have to recognize the
material
where the contact happened and finally
you will have to associate all of this
with the sounds that you hear
so we did that task we train a system to
solve this problem
and what i will show you now is the
result
of running that system on a silent video
so what you will see the input video
shows the drumstick hitting and
scratching a rock
but the system will only see the images
not the audio
what you will hear as i play this video
is the audio predicted by the system is
not the real audio that came with the
video
so let's play this
[Music]
and as you can hear the sound was
correctly temporarily aligned with the
moments in which the drumstick was in
contact with the surface
and the sounds corresponded to hits and
scratches
it was not perfect but the system shows
that it has learnt something about the
visual and auditory worlds without any
human supervision
so what has the system learned the
network has learned to represent
surface properties from visual
information only
that allows to discriminate among
different types of materials
a simple classifier train on the
self-learned features
can discriminate among different types
of materials
it will confuse materials that produce
similar sounds when hit with a drumstick
such as glass and metal which sound very
similar when you hit them with a drum
stick
but learning with sounds and images can
be done even without having to hit
everything with a drum stick in fact
when we are in a particular place
anywhere
we will always hear some sounds the
ambient sound dance
that surrounds us is a mixture of all of
the sounds that are made by the objects
that are present in the scene
so it's like thinking that the world
comes with its own soundtrack
and many objects in the world produce
sounds by themselves
of different kinds and the mind the main
cue
that we could use here is the temporal
coincidence
of hearing a particular sound and seeing
a particular visual pattern in the world
and then we can create an association
between that sound that we hear
and that particular visual pattern and
the fact that they seem to co-occur
time time over time
so we can now play the same cross model
prediction game that we did for the
drumstick
we will try to predict what type of
sounds are associated with a particular
image
and in this case the image will not
contain the drumstick it's just whatever
objects are there that are producing
sounds
and a model trained to solve this task
if it is successful
it will have to solve the following
problem you will have to be able to
recognize
and categorize the objects that are in
the scene
that are naturally associated with
ambient sounds
and you will have to associate them with
appropriate type of sound
that it goes with that object
so what has a network like that learned
we can now once we train such a system
we can look inside what the system has
learned
just in a similar way of how a
neuroscientist will look inside the
brain
look at the activations of the neurons
to try to understand how the brain works
we can perform the same thing on a
neural network that has been trained to
solve this task
and what we discover is that the network
inside the network some of the neurons
became specialized in detecting baby
faces
other units became specialized in
detecting crowds of people
and this is because baby faces babies
produce a particular type of sound
and whenever a baby face was present
that was the sound that was associated
with it
clouds also made a different type of
noise
and there are other units that are
selective to
waterfalls the ocean
and all of those units have learned to
detect
objects in images that are associated
with distinctive
types of sounds there are units that
will detect also the sky
because it comes with the sound of the
wind
and also cars
the important point here is that these
units have learned to detect these
objects
without requiring any type of human
supervision
just by learning from the temporal
association between
sounds and visual patterns
in particular for instance the car
selective unit
is capable of detecting cars but it has
never been
trained with a human having to annotate
cars in images
sensing images and audio has a long
history
but there are other types of sensory
modalities and in particular
one very important sensory modality for
humans
for which do not exist a mature
technology is
touched tactile information is essential
for humans
with a significant part of our brains
devoted to process tactile information
recorded by our skin
and there are a number of devices
commercial devices
and research devices that have developed
to measure
tactile information but it's still a
very small number
those devices are nowhere near the
quality and maturity
that cameras and microphones have
reached
we are developing tactile sensors
that will also record tactile
information
when a human interacts with an object in
this particular case
is a globe that a human can wear that
records
pressure signals and as you are
manipulating an object
it will record which parts of the hand
are in contact with
with the object and what is the strength
of that contact
this way we can develop approaches that
can use this measure tactile information
to perform
object recognition to measure object
properties
and so on
and it's not just about the hand
the same technologies can be extended to
cover large body surfaces
and eventually become a tactile sensing
skin for robots
so as i mentioned all these different
sensory modalities is what provides
now a way of learning from the temporal
coincidences between different events
across different senses and this will
provide
a method to learn about objects without
requiring
human annotations
besides interacting with the world there
are many other ways in which we learn
to recognize things so let's think of a
following game
let's say that i give you lots of images
and you have to play the following game
given a collection of images i want you
to draw
a new image that looks similar
to the images that i gave you it doesn't
need to be
one of the images that i gave you but it
has to look
as belonging to the same family
playing this game requires understanding
what the content of these pictures is
understanding the 3d geometry and then
drawing something
that looks similar to it and
current systems current neural networks
have been tackling this problem for some
time
and there has been a lot of progress in
recent years
there is a family of systems called
generative adversarial networks
that try to solve that problem given a
bunch of images
they want to be able to draw new images
that look
real
this approach was proposed in 2014 and
these are the type of images
that were produced by an artificial
system trying to
reproduce images that seem and look real
and as you can see they were very low
quality
very similar to the blurry movie that i
showed you at the beginning
two years later new advances were
capable of
drawing images like the ones that i'm
showing here
which are trying to look as bedrooms
they are not very good but you can see
that there has been a big
step forward and there are some
geometric figures that
look like they could come from the real
world although
no one would get will get full in
thinking that these are real images
but just two years later the advances
were so
big that systems were capable of
producing images that look like this
and therefore quite real
and since then there has been a lot of
progress
so the system what it does it starts
with a collection of images like these
ones that contains buildings
churches and castles and from this
collection
it will train to be able to generate new
images
that should look real the way in which
this neural network works
is it will take us input just a random
number
a random collection of numbers like
flipping a coin 512
500 times and recording just the
outcomes
this vector will get um
enter into a neural network that will
recombine this
set of numbers make it bigger recombine
again
enhance it recombine it until at the end
you end up with a picture and this
picture is a randomly generated image
if jews throw the coin multiple times
different times you will get
different set of images
so these are examples of images that are
not real images they are generated by
this neural network
and they look amazing they even have
watermarks because they were part of the
training set
but the question is to render images
that look so real
what is that this neural network has
really learned
does he know about objects how it is
capable of putting the pixels in the
right places
so that they look as sky trees and
buildings
is there a representation that explicit
that is explicit and it contains
some of these objects
so that's a question that we ask
ourselves and we started looking inside
the neural network
to see if it was discovering some of
these objects
and indeed what we found is that there
are units
in this inside the network that have
learned
to draw specific objects so in
particular for instance
in a particular layer layer number four
neuron 119
became a 3 specific unit
whenever that unit was activated a 3
will appear on the picture
another unit you need number 43
whenever that neuron was activated a
dome will appear on the picture
like in these images
there was another neuron neuron 84 that
was specialized in drawing
windows and whenever that neuron was
activated
a window will appear on the picture
and unit 315 was specialized in drawing
chairs
and whenever that unit will be activated
a chair will appear on the picture
so what is really interesting is that
these units
that are explaining some objects
appearing
or disappearing on the picture now we
can intervene on this neural network
and control what we want to have on the
picture
so for instance this image which is
randomly generated by the neural network
if we take the units that we know are
responsible of drawing windows
and we turn them off we tell them not to
get activated anymore in this picture
and then we render the resulting image
what we get is something like this
picture
which is very similar to the other one
but it doesn't have
windows and instead it has replaced the
window with a wall
and there seems to be a painting on the
wall
and the only thing that we have done is
to manually turn
off the units that we believe are
responsible of drawing windows
here is another example of a different
image that is drawing
[Music]
a conference room if we turn off the
window units
the windows in the background disappear
and they get replaced by diplomas
which seems to be an appropriate
decoration for a conference room
all these images are completely randomly
generated by
this neural network we can also ask the
neural network to do things that are
impossible
for instance this picture is very gray
and if we want to have more color we can
turn on
neutrons that we have found are
responsible of drawing grass
but we are going to activate those
neurons everywhere on the picture
and then the resulting is something like
this
where it seems as if humanity
is gone after a thousand years and you
can see
that you know grass is growing
everywhere
is growing on top of the building and
these are things that
this neural network never saw during
training
is putting objects in places where we
are asking it to do it
but this is something that the network
never saw during training
so the network seems to have learned to
represent
objects explicitly despite that again
there was no human annotations
no human had to indicate what a window
is what a car
is what grass is the network has learned
to associate
parts of the network with specific
objects
so this is part of this enterprise of
trying to learn
without supervision discovering what are
the
objects in the world through different
modalities and imagination
so that you do not require a teacher
or human annotators in order to train an
artificial system
my name is marcus buehler i'm the mcafee
professor of engineering at mit
and today i'll be presenting some of our
recent research on the molecular
mechanics of unfolding johann sebastian
bach
we all know johan sebastian bach as an
influential composer
that is still affecting musical creation
to this date
but have you thought of johann sebastian
bach as an inventor of new proteins
as a creator of new biochemistry we have
discovered that bach might have
inadvertently
created designed and realized new forms
of life new forms of proteins
new biomaterials that evolution has not
yet discovered
but they have been created through the
creation of musical art
this provides evidence for hidden
information
created across time scales created
across cultural information levels
to inform science today and perhaps the
future of
understanding life on this planet and
elsewhere
when you think about the formation of
the fundamental building blocks of life
you begin to think about proteins
proteins really are
the elementary ancient evolutionary
memories of a very distant past
during which evolution yielded the kind
of life we have on earth today
and that emerged over millions and
billions of years
proteins spontaneously come together or
fold
at very short time scales beginning with
time scales of 10 to the minus 15
seconds which are the
scales at which molecular connections
vibrate
on the other hand on the other side of
the spectrum we have human
created assemblies of structures such as
music
music is an assembly of pitches notes
different timbres or instruments
in complex arrangement in complex
hierarchical arrangements
that span multiple time and length
scales
through the assembly of nodes we can
induce emotional responses in our brain
through music we can convey messages
either direct messages obvious messages
or
subliminal messages that are underlying
currents in the musical creation
with the new tools of artificial
intelligence we can now make
new connections and discover hidden
physical realizations of information
in art to advance science humanity and
culture
there are structural forms in art that
we believe
can only now be discovered using modern
technologies
our research deals with multi-scale
materials we look at matter from a
multiple scale perspective
from the atomic scale where we have
dimensions of 10 to the minus 10
and smaller meters which are the scales
of atoms and orbitals and chemical
connections
and we go all the way up to the macro
level where we have scales at the human
level
of a couple of meters or the scale of
the planet
many many thousands of meters and
kilometers or to the scale of the
universe where we have even much larger
length scales
these materials can be looked at through
this microscope of different
magnifications and each level of
magnification we're going to see
different structural features these
structural features range from the
atomic scale
through the micro meso scale all the way
to the macro scale and materials derive
their functions their unique
properties such as color mechanical
properties optical properties
magnetic properties diffusive properties
and any other kind of technologically
important or culturally important
properties
through these features across these
different scales these are patterns
that humans in part have created or
nature creates all the time
during evolutionary processes
one of the fundamental processes we're
interested in is the breaking of
materials
materials break and characteristic time
scales of 10 to the minus 12 seconds
there's a universality of vibrations and
waves which occurs
at every observational level that we
have currently available
we have molecules which can be
understood based on a wave particle
duality
quantum scale objects behave either as a
wave or a particle
simultaneously we have sound waves of
course that's how we communicate that's
how animals communicate
and we have used sounds in the form of
music as a cultural expression
as a way of affecting memory and passing
on information through generations of
cultures
and of course we have the insect world
spiders bees
and wasps all communicate through
vibrations with tools we have now
available of artificial intelligence
molecular dynamics modeling
we can map these different time scales
on a single observational level
and actually make them understandable
through new processes in
the use of the human brain in the
beginning of the universe we had a
fairly even distribution of matter
small fluctuations of matter ultimately
led to the creation
of planets galaxies and all the things
we have today including atoms of course
localization of information localization
of energy or matter which are equivalent
leads to the creation of matter as we
know it today
in a very similar way when we look at
spiders as an animal that creates an
extraorganismal structure the spider web
it also does this using a very similar
mechanism a spider might eat a fly
the spider's world consists of eating
things
processing the things it has eaten in
the
body of the spider and then reassembling
these building blocks of what it has
eaten
into a structure from a distribution a
random distribution of protein building
blocks that the spider has
digested from eating the fly it can
create beautiful web structures as shown
here
and at the foundation of these web
structures of course are these protein
molecules and these protein molecules
are made by themselves from what we call
amino acids or ultimately encoded by dna
and these can be viewed as lego building
blocks so when the spider eats a fly
it essentially ingests a very large
number of lego building blocks
and it has a random collection of these
in its body and the spider has found an
ingenious way
to then reassemble these building blocks
these lego building blocks into a
structure
to organize them in space and in time to
create a certain material function which
in this case is the web function one of
the functions is to catch more prey
for the spider to survive here's the
result of an experimental analysis
where we observe the spider building a
web this is work in collaboration with
our
cast collaborator thomas saracino with
whom we watched the spider build a web
over a period of days
and you can see how the spider is truly
an autonomous 3d printer depositing
materials in space
choosing the location and thereby
creating a hierarchical structure that
is
both aesthetically beautiful but also
more importantly for the spider
functional and in a similar way when
life emerged
billions of years ago we're looking now
the evolutionary time scales
we had random processes random
fluctuations that created structure
the basic structure of the formation of
rna or other molecules
which ultimately created life as we know
today built from
dna proteins and other kinds of
biomolecules
and this led to the creation of all
sorts of different organisms as we know
today
and again these organisms have evolved
because
ultimately at the basic level molecules
assembled in particular structure from a
random distribution of molecules
a varying landscape that this planet was
billions of years ago
where then suddenly molecules begin to
arrange became living objects
living subjects which ultimately led to
the creation of the human race as we
know it today
music in a very similar way is an
election of localization of energy
this election is created for example
through the creative mind or
other processes or animals which use
sound or music to communicate
white noise is the equal distribution of
tonal energy at all frequencies creating
a chaotic
a random structure and we represent this
in our ear and our brains
as noise
this is in stark contrast to what we
identify as harmony
where instead of having a random
distribution of
information at all frequencies we now
have a distribution at very particular
frequencies
by playing tones at very particular
frequencies or a selection of
frequencies we can create
musical information and encode
information and create an oppression in
our brain that
causes an emotional response
here's an example where i begin playing
white noise
and then use this white noise as a basis
to create sound that we
we realize in our brain as music i use
the white noise and then filter out
only the harmonics these harmonics are
the building blocks
for very simple forms of music and you
can hear as the sound progresses
we go from white noise filtering out
information and only localizing energy
at these harmonic frequencies
into a single tone we can then play uh
music on the form of octaves by
using equal temperament tuning and even
create chord progressions
or other more complex sounds and as we
turn the filter off
we return back to the white noise so in
this case we have created
a random structure and we have localized
information we have localized energy and
created what we call
music or one of the forms of music that
we know as today
[Music]
do
[Music]
another way to create music is to start
from silence
and only create tones or sound that
reflects
certain types of frequencies or
vibrations
this is a localization of frequencies
that we typically use in the
conventional way of using analog
instruments like a vibrating string
these vibrating strings vibrate at very
particular frequencies we can tune them
by changing the tension or the length of
these strings
and we can then create music by having
different types of tuning systems
and plugging the strings differently or
borrowing them differently
and of course an example for
highlighting the emergence
of sound or music from silence is the
famous piece 433
the strings don't have to necessarily be
conventionally
tuned they don't have to look like in a
guitar or in a piano
or perhaps in a violin or viola or cello
these strings actually can also
come from nature and in some recent work
we have used spider webs
and used the individual strings in
spider webs as musical form as musical
creation process
and you can imagine that these strings
in the spider web are not tuned
according to any of the tuning system
we're usually familiar with
in fact they're tuned by the spider to
follow certain
rules and laws that the spider uses to
communicate but we can make them audible
and what you hear in the background is
an example of how these types of
vibrations sound like
it's a strange world but you can begin
to live in the world of the spider
and engage in the process of feeling a
little bit like a spider
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
music changes the state of mind and it
has affected our physicality so when you
listen to music when you hear sounds
you have a response in your brain it's a
physical real response
things are changing in your brain things
are changing material changes are
happening
as you listen to music before and after
is different
our question now is can these material
changes
yield actual new material form instead
of changing our brain
a state of the molecules in our brain
the chemicals in our brain the cells the
neurons
can we utilize music as a way of
creating
new material form or perhaps new life
forms
for example can we create new
biomaterials can we create new types of
cells
can we create new proteins this has been
the topic of my research in the last
couple of years
and we asked the question how can we
bring resonances
and motions from the distant past
perhaps from composers that have
composed music created music
hundreds maybe even thousands of years
ago to the future
and how can we analyze them understand
them and actually use them to create
new kinds of material expressions and
extract information that's not obvious
subliminal information that's hidden in
the musical structure
we can use this approach to better
understand materials we can use it to
define
new musical forms as a new way of
composing music of creating music
and we can also learn about ourselves
because this music is created by humans
and by studying what humans create and
what hidden messages we might be sending
we can communicate across generations so
again you have
a multitude of length scales and time
scales involved here
in this process proteins
are the hardware of life an introduction
to proteins essentially begins with the
level of dna dna
is essentially the coding structure it's
elementary
to understand how life is built it's the
building plan for that
dna encodes the way proteins are
actually
physically constructed how the amino
acids in proteins are put together
ultimately the protein folds at these
micro millisecond time scales to form
ultimately living subjects and these
living subjects have functions
they form perhaps cells in a body they
form
organisms organs they can form tissues
our skin you can think about your eyes
all of these things are really truly
made from proteins so proteins are the
workhorse
the actual materialization of life and
in the evolution
this plays a very important role
proteins are evolving of course through
genetic mutations through natural
selection
and these processes lead to different
life forms so all these different life
foams have
different kinds of proteins some
proteins have survived evolutionary
processes
and are found across different species
other types of
protein molecules are only found in one
species and maybe in one particular
niche ecologically
now how do proteins look like when you
open the textbook and you look into
molecular structures
you're going to find a picture like this
and you're going to find a chemical
structure usually other water molecules
maybe some metal ions
and really reflecting a complex for the
geometry and
thereby deriving chemical biochemical
and evolutionary functions but
if you think about proteins and
molecules in general that's really not
how they look like if you take a real
microscope and you watch the molecular
motions which now we can actually image
experimentally you can see that these
atoms and molecules are actually
continuously
moving and vibrating as these molecules
continuously vibrate and move
they follow equations of motions which
ultimately are governed by quantum
chemistry
these quantum chemical laws can be
implemented in an algorithm called
molecular dynamics and we can actually
watch
simulate and observe the motions of
these molecules these
vibrations happen on the scale of 10 to
the minus 15 seconds
and higher so these are very very short
time scales compared to the scale of
observation of the human
human mind for instance and if you look
at a simulation of a protein this is an
alpha helical protein
you can see that these vibrations
jittering motions are quite interesting
quite beautiful
very elegant and you can see they have
certain patterns with them and these
patterns are associated with certain
structural features we can distinguish
different kinds of proteins
by watching different kinds of features
or patterns emerge at these
very very short time scales now these
vibrational
signatures are the elementary
description of life
proteins are made from 20 naturally
occurring amino acids
and each of these 20 amino acids we've
discovered has a unique vibrational
signature
they vibrate in different forms in
different ways and these vibrational
signatures are sort of bar codes for the
elementary building blocks of life
and this represents a localization of
energy just as we talked about it during
the creation of the universe
unveiling a long time ago during the
emergence of life
during the creation of music through the
human creative mind in all of these
processes there's a common thread a
common theme that we localize
structure we put things in a certain
place we move things at the other place
or we don't even put that beginning
and thereby we create a distribution a
patterning and
the way life emerges is creating
patterns across these 20 amino acids now
these 20 amino acids can be made audible
this information
is stored at very high frequencies and
naturally we cannot hear them our
auditory system
can only hear up to about 20 kilohertz
we can solve this problem by using the
concept of transposition or
transpositional equivalence as this
simple example shows i'm beginning to
play a melody
in the beginning at very high
frequencies and i'm slowly moving down
i'm transposing this
this piece of music into lower and lower
frequencies
until it becomes audible so as you
listen pay close attention and see at
what point you actually recognize
what melody i'm playing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once you have recognized the melody i'm
playing it again i'm transposing it
again to lower frequencies and
to your ear to your brain you can
clearly still identify that this is the
same melody it's four leaves by
beethoven
however i'm playing it at yet lower
frequencies
and this is what we call transposition
equivalence we can play melodies at
different frequency levels
by keeping the ratios the multipliers of
frequencies
the same and thereby we retain musical
information structural information that
is elementary to understanding
through the auditory system in our brain
what kind of sound has been created and
what that means for
for processing in the brain in a similar
way we can use this
to translate proteins into audible
spectrum
and what you hear in the background now
are all these 20 amino acid building
blocks played in a succession and you
can hear that each of these 20 amino
acid building blocks
has a unique tone associated with it
it's kind of like having its own
key on a keyboard or piano however this
is not a typical piano because the
tuning system
of course now is a different one it's a
distinct tuning system that we call the
amino acid scale
it follows the quantum mechanical loss
by which these 20 naturally occurring
amino acids actually vibrate
we can thereby map proteins to sound
what you hear in this example here
is the mapping of a protein called
lysozyme it's an enzyme
that's been studied for many decades
this protein has been translated now
through this process
into a music piece
[Music]
in this process we also recognize the
folding of molecules
by playing melodies against each other
creating a sort of counterpoint
emergence a counterpoint function that
is very similar for example
to brian eno's work using tapes so these
tapes you can imagine are the amino acid
or dna sequences
that are folded on top of one another
thereby forming more complex musical
form
than just the sequence and we also
incorporate of course higher level
structural information
such as the vibrations at higher length
scales and time scales
as well as secondary structures these
are the distinctions between an alpha
helix or beta sheet
each of these have unique auditory
signatures which can be made audible so
we're creating a symphony
of auditory information that encodes the
three-dimensional structure of a protein
from the very basic level of amino acid
sequences
all the way to the structural folding
scale
and this can be applied not only to the
amino acid scale we can actually
approximate the amino acid scale
using conventional tuning systems such
as equal temperament tuning
and convert these types of protein cells
these kinds of protein music
into a form of western classical music
and play them using an orchestra and
we've done this recently
in a piece where we have sonified the
antibody
to the covalent 19 pathogen that forms
when you take a vaccine
or that forms when you're naturally ill
from this virus your body produces these
antibodies which
interact with the virus and these
vibrational interactions this
system of vibrating atoms and molecules
that interact the virus with the
antibody trying to defeat it
is what you hear in the following
example which is set in a classical
score reflecting the information
in this particular protein system this
piece has been played by the lindenburg
orchestra in korea who have realized
this in an orchestral setting
[Music]
so
[Music]
why are we interested in translating
proteins to music beyond the aesthetic
approach beyond maybe an as an
interesting way of creating new musical
form
creating new musical competition to
inspire us to create
interesting musical structures we can
also use this to design new proteins we
can create
training sets for artificial
intelligence algorithms from this
process
imagine having a large database of
proteins thousands hundreds of thousands
of proteins
which we can then translate into music
we can let an ai algorithm listen to all
of these proteins
and let the ai compose new music
this new music can then be translated
back into a protein structure
this approach has been very successful
and we have used this to actually make
new proteins in lab
that we've designed through music i
should mention that instead of having ai
create music
of course we can also have a human
composer create music and write music
in the same form or style as these
proteins produce so we can learn these
these processes we can learn the
patterns
the rhythms the folding the interactions
the counterpoint structures
and utilize these to thereby create new
proteins
but using ais of course is a perhaps
simpler way
because it's not influenced not biased
in any way by the kinds of musical
impressions that we all have
by listening to all the other music
we've ever heard in our life
this is the way by which we translate
music
into a new kind of protein a new kind of
material we begin
this process by creating a musical score
these musical scores include all the
information about the notes the volume
the rhythms
and the counterpoint information as well
and then we translate these sequences
into a sequence of dna building blocks
this dna sequence then forms the basic
instruction set for cells in this case
we've used e coli cells
to then express this protein then the
cells
make the protein and we can basically
slice the cell open
and extract the protein and purify it
and put it in a test tube what you see
on the right hand side
is how such a test tube looks like which
includes this protein that was designed
purely based on music now this protein
is a what we call denovo protein it
doesn't exist in nature
so through this musical approach we have
discovered instead of using evolution as
a way
over a very long time scale we've used
in a very elegant way
musical creation as a way of designing
and realizing in material form a new
protein
so now we're going to do an experiment
let's listen to
the beginning of the aria in a box
goldberg variation
and the question is what kind of
information is stored
in this very beautiful but very simple
succession of notes of rhythms
and by analyzing this music that bach
road a couple hundred years ago
we can assign each of the musical notes
in the area at the beginning of the area
into a succession of dna codes by
assigning unique
associations with these vibrations of
amino acids
this dna code can then be formed as a
basis into a protein expression just
like we've done before
in an experimental way by putting these
amino acid sequences or dna sequences
into a cell
in this case we've put this into a deep
learning and machine learning algorithm
these machine learning algorithms have
the capacity to predict
how these amino acid building blocks
fold or assemble at these
micro to millisecond time scales and
form a material
and these algorithms can also predict of
course whether material form or not and
that's a big question because
some of the successions of notes or
rhythms will not ever form a protein
there are certain rules by which these
musical creations in this
in this protein amino acid scale must
follow and the experiment here is
manifold one of them is did bug actually
inadvertently create a protein that can
actually be folded and is stable or not
and the algorithm has predicted a very
surprising result so we use the steep
learning algorithm to fold the protein
and we discovered that in fact the the
first 146 notes of the arya
indeed lead to an actual protein that is
stable and you see on the right hand
side how it looks like so we went from
the musical form they could hear into a
ladder of dna
sequences protein amino acid sequences
to ultimately a protein structure that
we have folded
and you can now see and watch now this
protein
is sort of the realization of this music
so i have on this slide
a comparison of the musical score on the
very left the original musical score
um and the right-hand side you see the
protein you can see again on this
example here that the protein isn't
static as i mentioned in the very
beginning
a protein like this is continuously
moving and vibrating right so these
atoms are not
sitting still they are like mini strings
mini meaning
at the scale of 10 to the minus 10
meters so very very tiny strings or
connections between the atoms the
chemical bonds
they vibrate and they have a certain
signature certain vibrational signature
now what we've done on this experiment
we've taken
this protein that we've created based on
box composition
and translated this protein again into
music so the question is
can we certify this protein essentially
instead of taking an existing protein
that evolution has produced as i've done
before with lysozyme the enzyme
we ask now the question can we convert
this protein created by bach
inadvertently of course
into a new musical structure and how
would that sound like
here uh we're going to listen to that
piece now and what you
hear in this example is the protein that
was folded based on box code migration
area the first 146 notes
including all the information about how
the protein folds the secondary
structures the rhythm
the counterpoints you can see the
counterpoint map on the right-hand side
and we can see what kind of interesting
new music comes
out of that process
[Music]
so what this experiment has shown is
that the the music that we have created
has new information and the new
information has been added
by using the deep learning algorithm to
really
incorporate truly the ancient memory of
evolution the angioma revolution is
essentially the building blocks the laws
by which proteins
fold from the sequence and this folding
this chemical information this basic
life information the living system
information
has now been incorporated into this note
sequence that bach created
and thereby created new musical
information new sound information that
was not there before and actually has
created
a piece that is about five minutes long
in this case
this new protein is different from any
protein that has been created by
evolution
in fact we have checked this protein
against any known databases of proteins
and it doesn't exist
so bach has actually created through
this process of writing down notes
new proteins we can now make this
protein in the laboratory and analyze
what kind of function it has now
the functions it might have it could be
an enzyme it could be a structural
material in other words it could be a
strong and tough material
like in hair or fingernails it could be
a virus
it could be a pathogen it could be a
poison
you know it could be a hormone protein
and we don't know what it is and this is
where
um of course much further research is
needed to understand the exact function
of this
protein encoded by bach
[Music]
but more broadly this process has also
enabled us to create a new way of
composing music so instead of writing
down notes
we can write down notes and then ask a
deep learning algorithm to incorporate
new information new
secret or hidden information in this
process and through this process we can
incorporate information across
very very long time scales and length
scales essentially looking at the
evolutionary time scales
during which life and all the proteins
have evolved and
this creates a new set of musical ideas
that we can utilize perhaps in
composition
or in the writing of future musical
forms
so a couple of things we have understood
or learned from this experiment
one question you could ask why isn't the
music
yet comes out of sonifying the protein
we have created from bach
the same as in the beginning and the
answer is that of course the folding
process
has added new information so we have
utilized a different medium a different
expression of information
the quantum chemistry the evolutionary
time scales and added this information
into the folding and ultimately into the
listening experience and so
the music has changed after the
expression has a protein from the dna
sequence that bach originally invented
and this is a passage of information
through
a very different time scale horizon of
course
that includes the vibrations of the
atoms which ultimately make the sound
the music you hear
but the memory that we have incorporated
of course comes from a very very distant
past
so ai can help us to create art or
particular music as we've talked about
here in this presentation
but it really does not replace humans it
can be a tool for humans
to become more creative or to get
information and answers from a distant
past
we like to use proteins as a way of
gaining information
musical ideas about things that have
happened in evolutionary time scales we
like to interrogate
proteins and molecules to see to hear
what is happening at the scale of
vibrations of amino acids or between
atoms and looking at atomic bonds
like a guitar string that we can excite
and watch and hear and use as a way of
creating a new
scaling system like the amino acid scale
but in all of this process
even though computers and ai can help us
we still need a significant input of
course and artistic choices
by the human especially once we want to
create artistically
interesting aesthetically pleasing
products that we can
process and understand in our brains so
the creation of music is really a deeply
human experience
it's a way of mapping out memory of deep
time
and the individual and collective
process by which music is created
performed improvised
exposed on analyzed on derived for
future evolutions of musical
cultural musical creation is really an
unconscious act
to create consciousness of the past and
this concept
is artistically very interesting it's
also scientifically very interesting
because using music as a way of looking
inside ourselves to looking
at these distant primordial memories of
structures that might have happened
during the emergence of life billions of
years ago here on this planet
perhaps even further deeper in time
during the
emergence of the universe as a whole
where quantum fluctuations have emerged
and i think this is a very interesting
direction for the current and future
research in my
lab to explore whether these
relationships can be
brought out whether we can make them
audible uh whether we can
connect them mathematically using
concepts like category theory
to other principles and organization of
information and thereby solve of course
ultimately important cultural problem or
scientific problem or
to advance the ability of humans to
create music
and to create this beautiful abstract
form of art
that allows us to transmit information
emotions
without ever using a single word so the
opportunities ahead are manifold we can
see that
by looking at multiple scales in a
material
you can watch individual molecules move
you can watch
spiders build webs we can make spider
webs into instruments we can make
molecules and instruments we can hear
music everywhere really we can hear the
sound everywhere and
this uh tradition of course of using
sonification or the tradition of
listening to the environment or
understanding
how silence or the lack of music the
expectation
uh like in 433 yields this particular
result of paying close attention to
nature
close attention to the environment is
powerful
and with the tools of ai molecular
dynamics multi-scale experimentation
microscopes really whether computational
real microscopes
we can look inside materials and
understand a lot of these principles at
a very deep and foundational level
and what you hear now in this last
example is
music created during the fracturing
process by analyzing
the stress tense
[Music]
i'd like to thank you very much for your
interest and for your time
please be in touch by email if you have
questions follow me on my soundcloud
page where you can hear a lot of
examples of
music created from proteins music
created from fractures
and sounds of spiderwebs and of course
you can also
follow me on twitter where i post
information about my latest research
on a regular basis thank you very much
and i see you hopefully soon in the
panel
you